[Music]
it is so nice to meet you guys what's
going on tell me about life how are you
how's work
so you want to marry my daughter
yes yes I do
so do you hang out in the hood all the
time or do you just come up here for our
food and women it's a valid question
it is
maybe it would be a very nice baby mixed
race people are really awesome you know
you have like Mariah and Derek Jeter and
then of course you have the goat the
goat
the greatest of all time yeah I know
what it means but who are you referring
to our guy the legend Malcolm X
what in the mother what's the difference
between me and you and she's not
pregnant
because we don't even do that much
stuff she's not a prude she knows her
way around it and that's dad and I
respect and then what I'm saying is I
love your daughter and I would make a
good husband
ain't this about the [ __ ] where's our
waiter I am starving what's the
difference between me and you you talk a
good wine but you don't know what you're
supposed to do
foreign
[Music]